The process of configuration is also related to planning.
You can consider a planner that actually generates the plan in this plan
obstruction hierarchy. But then for any plan in this plan obstruction hierarchy,
then it converts a plan in this plan obstruction hierarchy into a skeletal plan.
It drops the values of the variables in the plans and constructs it
into a plan it's simply specify the variable without specifying the values.
The process of configuration planning then, takes these plans,
organizes them into obstruction hierarchy and goes about [INAUDIBLE] shading and
refining and expanding them. We already discussed how configuration is
connected to a number of other lessons like case based reasoning, planning and
classification. You may also consider this plan to be kind of strict for
physical object. In addition, this plans have been learned,
through learning methods similar to the method of incremental concept learning.
In addition, this plan hierarchy might be learned through learning methods
similar to the method for incremental concept learning. One of the things that
we are doing in knowledge based AI is, to describe the kinds of knowledge that
we need to learn. Before we decide on what is a good learning method, we need to
decide on what is it we need to learn? The configuration process tells us
of the different kinds of knowledge that then become targets of learning.
To connect this lesson back to our cognitive architecture,
consider this figure once again. So knowledge of the prototypical chair,
as well as knowledge about the radius, plans, and the abstraction hierarchy
are stored in memory. As the input gives specification with the design problem,
the reasoning component instantiates those plans, refines them and expands them.
The knowledge itself is learned through examples of configuration of
chairs that presumably, the agent is already encountered previously.